now of course we're in the the age of
zoom well
do all those meetings that you're doing
actually need to be
conducted via video because for a lot of
people
and this is true for extroverts too um
the video component of zoom
adds a whole other layer of exhaustion
um for lots of reasons that we could
talk about
and is it really necessary a lot of
people listening to this are like
um like praise be if i could just turn
off the videos
exactly yeah there's so many things
wrong with um
with video conferencing but i think the
biggest really is
the way in which you can't make
you have this choice between you know
staring into the camera
in order to make it seem as if you're
having eye contact with a person
versus are you actually having eye
contact with the person who you're
looking at
i think that that's especially an
especially exhausting dilemma
for introverts because if you're
somebody who
is not always so comfortable with every
social interaction
one of the best ways to override that
discomfort
is through tapping into your natural
empathy and your natural curiosity for
the person who you're speaking with
and when you can't actually look them in
the eye without
them feeling as if you're not looking
them in the eye that
interrupts that whole process yeah the
the am i looking at the camera am i
looking at the person's face
choice it's an awful choice
[Music]
welcome back to yank speaks this is your
co-host zach grauman
doing a quick intro before we hop into
the episode i hope you guys are well
this is
one of our first in a while audio only
episodes of yang speaks now why are we
audio only i know many of you very
disappointed not to see our beautiful
or funny looking faces depending who
you're asking but the reality is the
news of the week
andrew yang has coronavirus it's very
scary
as always um to get the virus we're all
locked down for
um but he's doing well he's feeling
better he feels like he has a heavy flu
thank you all for many of you have
tweeted and commented instagram
to send some love and we've passed that
on to him and he sees it and the reality
is
he's one of the hardest working people
i've ever met he's an energizer bunny
just keeps going and going so he's like
we're doing the podcast let's go we're
doing it
um we're just not gonna put it on video
because i look like crap it's true he's
kind of been
uh in a state of sick quarantine which
is not fun
um for anyone particularly him so
thoughts and prayers to andrew he's
feeling better he'll be back on his feet
very soon i hope to be back to
regular on-camera programming next week
so we've got
susan kane on today she has written
multiple books and does a ton of
research on the power of being an
introvert
um now for those of you listening who
are extroverts like me i'm if i do the
myers-briggs test i am 100
an extrovert the cross i bear folks i'm
just uh
like i get my energy um from people
and that is in many ways awesome
um because there's a lot of things in
society that are set up for extroverts
but in other ways it can put people off
and so i learned a lot
by understanding helping um have susan
explain
how introversion works and how people
can get energy from themselves which is
what introverts are and i know andrew's
an introvert and he's taught me a lot
about this as well
so i think you guys are going to find
this one fascinating she is
brilliant and um talks about a topic
that not a lot of people talk about and
i think it's really important for those
who listen to this and
understanding how human beings are wired
how we get our energy
um so i hope you guys enjoy a lesson on
what
introverts are and how to understand
them with susan kane
here on yang speaks
i want to tell you guys about one of the
most ultimate life hacks and it's called
blinkist
and what blinkist is is a shortcut to
sounding smart
uh at least that's how i see it but
reality is it is a way to simplify
long books so you can get the gist of
and get the main takeaways
um it's designed for busy people so
blink is super unique and it works on
your phone your tablet your web browser
whatever you prefer
it takes the best key takeaways the need
to know information
from thousands of non-fiction books and
condenses them down in just 15 minutes
that you can read or listen to
blinkist is made for busy people like
yourself i want to get the main points
from a book quickly so you can use that
information
right away in real time and with its
audio feature
you don't have to read it on your phone
it can just finish the book while you're
commuting
on your lunch break or if you're lying
around during coronavirus 12 million
people are already using blinkist right
now
including yours truly they have a
massive growing library from self-help
to business to health
to history books you name it with
blinkist you get an unlimited access to
read or listen to a massive library of
condensed non-fiction books
all the books you want for one low price
so right now for a limited time blinkis
has a special offer for just our
audience go to blinkist.com
yang and try it free free for seven days
and save 25
off your new subscriptions the blinkist
you spell it b l i
n k i s d like you blink blinkist.com
yang start your free seven day trial and
then get some 25
off your new subscription pretty awesome
blinkist.com yang
[Music]
i am so excited to welcome to yang
speaks
an intellectual role model of mine i've
admired for
quite some time who actually had a
profound impact on my family i don't
know
if she knows that the author of quiet
the power of introverts in a world that
can't stop talking
susan kane welcome susan oh my gosh
thank you so much andrew it's such an
honor to be here with you
and i don't think i knew about the
profound impact on your family so
i would love to hear about that at some
point well our older son was very
introverted and so my wife picked up
your book
and it had a big impact on
us as a family it led
my wife and i to dig in deeper to our
son's nature
it turns out that he's on the autism
spectrum so it was
even more than introversion
but i i think your explanation of
introversion as someone who gets over
stimulated
by certain types of situations was
something that really hit home for us
because our son uh was over stimulated
very easily at a young age
yeah and there is a real overlap there
also for
for kids and adults who are on the
autism spectrum with that sensitivity to
stimulation
that is such a big aspect of it that i
think people don't
they it's not only that they don't
understand it i think people aren't
aware of the myriad ways that
sensitivity to stimulation comes up in
day-to-day life like you've probably
now become aware of it but you know your
average
manager let's say thinking about
scheduling the 17th zoom call of the day
is probably not thinking about the ways
in which
zoom can be highly over for
half the people who are participating in
the call i have a running joke susan
that i say zoom
is powered by human souls
yes meaning like the the souls are
depleted by the time you're done with
the zoom
oh my soul is definitely depleted and so
i i have this image in my mind of like a
giant battery
somewhere that that's just like going up
in power
the more of us you zoom i shouldn't joke
because zoom is a very valuable tool
but one of the reasons why your book was
impactful was that i was a very
introverted kid
very bookish and nerdy
like to read science fiction you know
what's wild is in your book you even
talk about how
asian americans have a tendency towards
introversion and then that ends up
challenging their self-esteem when they
hit 12 years old because they end up
hitting an environment that then
values different qualities which is
something that i experienced
so i kind of had that self-esteem
challenge
at age 12 on it was really difficult
it's wild because at this point i
am theoretically very extroverted in
terms of
action but i still feel myself to be an
introvert
and that definitely was true on the
presidential trail
when after a full day of campaigning i
would often
feel very very depleted um
and need just to stare into space for a
while
can imagine and um i you know
the first question of course that's
going through my mind is
your choice of profession and your
choice to
to pursue the presidency is that
something that you're doing
um despite your
true temperament it's uh what
i think uh you refer to in the book as
like free trait theory where if you
uh really feel strongly about something
then you can get yourself to do it
i think that was the adaptation i made
um well before
i ran for president uh it was actually
when
i tried to start a business in my 20s
because like you i was
an unhappy corporate attorney um
but i lasted only five months at davis
pope
i i thought to myself at the time that i
had gotten the best job i could get
based upon
schooling um you know like uh davis pope
is a great firm
and then i said well if i'm going to
have the kind of career i want for
myself i'm going to have to
develop these other qualities those
qualities were around
entrepreneurship and salesmanship to a
degree
and so during that time i said okay i
guess i'm gonna have to get better at
these things if i'm going to be able to
have the kind of career i want for
myself or impact i want to have
it's really interesting to me though
because i
think you know as somebody who who sees
your political career
more from afar that one of the
strengths that you have is that you come
across as
a regular person who's in politics as
opposed to
as a career politician or somebody who's
been grooming to be a politician all his
life
and um and so i i think in a way you're
doing what many introverts
learn to do which is to make of their
natural tendency
a strength but to to make it in their
own image instead of trying to be
some other type of person well thank you
once
that's very high praise i still wince a
little bit if someone calls me a
politician honestly
um though it's factually accurate i mean
like like i don't take it as like a
you know an insult or anything so i have
to say susan
it is almost impossible for a book
to genuinely set off a revolution of
some kind
but i think that your book actually did
it
[Laughter]
and i laughed but you struck such a
chord
and then there were so many people that
were kind of suffering in silence
but before your book came along
and then it it feels like you kind of
unlocked or unleashed all of this
uh suffering and potential energy around
trying to build workplaces
and a society that are more mindful of
folks
who become overstimulated by various
social situations
it's it's really been incredible how did
you
end up plugging into this work initially
and then tell us about
really the last number of years because
this book came
out in 2012 and since then you've had
two ted talks
uh two sequels to the book uh a genuine
organization that is actually making a
huge difference in people's lives
so this is a very long-winded way of
asking
first did you ever imagine that it was
going to reach this level when you first
started writing this book
oh my gosh not at all um
so you know my path was like you i was a
corporate lawyer at a
very similar firm i was at cleary
gottlieb and
um but i i had always wanted to be a
writer since i was a kid
and um and when i stopped practicing
i wrote all kinds of things for a few
years never
tried to publish anything but i was
writing plays and essays and
poetry and memoir all kinds of stuff
and and then i started working on this
project about
introverts and i thought of it
as this quirky project that i was doing
on the side
for some reason this was the project
that i decided i was going to actually
try to get published you know as opposed
to all the other stuff i'd been
writing but even though i was
i started working on a book proposal and
you know went into the whole publishing
thing
um yeah i thought of it as my
quirky idiosyncratic take on the world
um i thought i'd be happy if the book
got published and
you know and a few people bought it but
i had no idea of the nerve it was going
to tap when i first started working on
it you know for the
for the reason that i think you just
touched on which is
most people have been experiencing
what it's like to be an introvert in an
extroverted culture
in silence no one ever talks about it no
one ever did talk about it
um so i didn't know that so many people
felt that way
and i also didn't know so many people
who felt that way would
be so happy to come forward and start
chatting about it
as they did but i got my first inkling
when my agent and i
first pitched the book proposal to the
publishing houses and
you know it set off this crazy auction
and i um
started meeting with all the different
houses and one by
having all these meetings and one by one
everybody started identifying themselves
as introverts
um so i'm sure the publishing world is
very introvert heavy
it is it is but so this is the thing
that kept happening so you could
so so that's what i said to myself you
know that was when i it was all just
beginning and i thought okay well that's
just the publishing world
that's a really introverted space right
because it's
book people um but then
some years later after i'd written it
the book came out and the first thing i
did practically was give a ted talk
about it
um and you know you know ted is this
environment
of all these sort of mover shaker type
people um
lots of ceos and people uh
kind of striding across the world in one
way or another um
but in that environment too i i happened
to be one of the first speakers
and i came off the stage and was
immediately surrounded by all these
other people all these people who were
telling me that
they too were secret introverts and they
had never talked about it before or they
had never even
realized it themselves but that's really
who they were
and uh and this is what started to
happen no matter what environment
uh i found myself in you know like half
the people were talking about how
intensely uh this described their story
something like a quarter to a half of
all people are introverts is that
correct
yeah that's right there's different
studies and so one study found that it
was about a third
of americans and another study 50
so you know i think we're safe to
estimate that it's one out of every
two or three people that you know you
know so
that's a lot of people in your family in
your workplace
in your campaign anywhere you go
[Music]
all right this episode of yank speaks is
brought to you by literati kids
great children's books open up new
worlds for discovery and with literary
kids you've got this try before you
buy subscription book clubs every month
literati delivers five vibrantly
illustrated children's books bringing
the immersive magic reading right to
your home
literati's age based book club ensures
appropriate reads
for your budding bookworm whether
they're snuggling with you for story
time or letting their imagination roam
free
it's like the one time in your life
you're innocent enough to just like fall
into a book and literati kids we love
that we want to have that with your kids
or your friends kids
or anyone you know in your life that has
a child no more sorting through hundreds
of titles trying to guess what the kid
will like or what your child is going to
enjoy literary is going to curate this
for you
sending you the best in children's
literature and you can choose to
purchase the ones they love and send the
rest back
for free pretty cool head to
literary.com yang for 25
off your first two orders select your
child's book club whichever age you like
and start them on that literary journey
like no other so that's literati.com
yang the only place you can get 25 off
your first two orders
and this one-of-a-kind book subscription
it's pretty freaking cool i've given it
as a gift before
kids love it they love books and this is
a great way to pick the right one so
literati l-i-t-e-r-a-t-i
dot com slash yang that's literati.com
yang
[Music]
so you pitch your book
uh there's a frenzy around it you're
like huh that's different
[Laughter]
yeah that's a good way of putting it it
was a kind of a bemusement
you do a ted talk and you realize that a
lot of the techies
were introverted nerds too which does
not shock me
right
right chris anderson knew from the
beginning um he had a sense that the
audience would
would resonate so then the book takes
off
and then what is that time like yeah so
then after that
it just became um a kind of non-stop
whirlwind from one world to another
um i mean okay so first of all it was
like hundreds or thousands
of letters and conversations and
so on with just one human after another
um talking about how
this concept was giving them a sense of
permission
finally to be who they are who they
actually are
and that word permission is the word
that people use over and over again
um like i don't think we realize
that the degree to which it just becomes
habit for
introverts to not feel permission to do
what they want to do
um you know and it's as some as simple
as like okay how are you going to spend
your free saturday afternoon
you know you might really want to just
be hanging out
by yourself and there's just this
feeling that gets bred into us from a
very early age that there's something
wrong with that choice so
so the first answer to your question is
that it was just this incredibly
moving and humbling series
of conversations with one
one person after another you know
talking about their life experiences
and then the other aspect of it has been
watching the ways in which
these ideas can really improve
institutions you know whether you're
talking about schools
or sports teams or or companies
and i've been so gratified to see
how open and willing people are to
embrace these these kinds of ideas you
know because the message is kind of like
well
you know as an institution this
this if i'm speaking to a school or if
i'm speaking to a company
the message is well as an institution
you haven't been getting it right
thus far and and you can imagine that
being
a message that people would resist but
that hasn't happened
i've found instead that people are
really receptive and you know they get
it
we're talking about half of our
population why would we not want to
get it right why why would we not want
to make a few tweaks that would
harness the energies and the talents of
half our population
why would we not do that i've seen this
adopted now
in every kind of institution that you
can imagine
and it's just incredibly exciting let's
say that someone listening to this right
now
is a manager and he's thinking oh
you mean like maybe there's something i
can do that will actually help some of
my
people feel more comfortable or be in
better position to produce
like what kind of tweaks are we talking
about in a typical organization how do
they
do things customarily and then how
might they tweak it well there's really
a lot
you know the number one thing would be
getting this to
just be a subject that people talk about
readily and comfortably and
where you can kind of just joke around
with each other about
what everyone's temperament is like i'm
just thinking of a conversation that i
had with
a professor bob sutton business school
professor
and he was talking about how so many
so many academics are introverts and
that there's a way in which many
academic institutions
make it comfortable for their professors
to be that way and i asked him
well what do they do to make it
comfortable and he said you know
it's it's a kind of intangible thing
it's just a kind of joking around of
like yeah of course
um you're going to want you just taught
a class of course you're going to want
to go off and take a break now
it's just it's an affectionate
comfortable easy joking around
about these differences so so the first
thing i'm talking about is a
just a sort of shift of consciousness
but in terms of specifics
there's a lot um one thing would be to
be become more mindful of how many
meetings you are having and how many of
them
are actually necessary and then when you
do need to meet um as a staff
as a team how how are those meetings
conducted
and how much exhausting
self-presentation
is involved as opposed to just the
pure exchange of ideas or the pure
enjoyment of each other's company
um so you know now of course we're in
the age of zoom
well do all those meetings that you're
doing actually need to be
conducted via video because for a lot of
people
and this is true for extroverts too um
the video component of zoom
adds a whole other layer of exhaustion
um
for lots of reasons that we could talk
about and is it really necessary
a lot of people listening to this are
like um
like praise be if i could just turn off
the videos
exactly yeah there's so many things
wrong with um
with video conferencing but i think the
biggest really is
the way in which you can't make
you have this choice between you know
staring into the camera
in order to make it seem as if you're
having eye contact with a person
versus are you actually having eye
contact with the person who you're
looking at
i think that that's especially an
especially exhausting dilemma
for introverts because if you're
somebody who
is not always so
comfortable with every social
interaction one of the best ways to
override
that discomfort is through tapping into
your natural empathy
and your natural curiosity for the
person who you're speaking with
and when you can't actually look them in
the eye
without them feeling as if you're not
looking them in the eye
that interrupts that whole process yeah
the
the am i looking at the camera am i
looking at the person's face
choice it's it's an awful choice
it's an awful choice i i it's a really
it's a soul disrupting choice
it's not just a technical choice but
then there's other things that we can do
too
so things like opening up a meeting with
a kind of
round robin where everybody is given
their
appointed time to speak as opposed to
having to jockey for position
is very helpful for anybody who is
either
bio biologically introverted or
more introverted for reasons of gender
conditioning or cultural
aspects or whatever the reason there's a
lot of different reasons
that that some people are
going to be a lot more hesitant to
feel that they're interrupting someone
else or to kind of jockey for air space
so the more that airspace can be granted
without you having to go through that
process
the more help the more you might hear
from everyone at one of my organizations
we had a rubric called substance to word
ratio
does the person actually deliver like
high substance to word
um because if someone's just
talking a lot but like not that not that
um substantively then you know their
ratio was low
and so this was something that we used
as like a signal to people um so that it
wasn't just
that like to reward volume
um but it was trying to point out
thoughtfulness
i love that was that your idea that was
my idea the substance-to-word ratio it
was one of like the the rubrics that was
used and then
after people heard that that was a
rubric behavior changes completely
because all of a sudden like the people
that like to do a lot of talking all of
a sudden are like
wait a minute maybe i should like uh
reign it in a little bit
that is so interesting so it actually
worked like it actually changed
behaviors
yeah yeah it did um feel free to adopt
anyway i love it i mean the substance
toward ratio
[Applause]
okay raise your hand if you're having a
miserable time this pandemic
i was talking to my grandma and she said
uh that she calls the pandemic the
pandamik
which is funny because she never swears
so she's pushing 90. anyway bless her
heart
i thought it was hilarious and and so
this is one of the reasons we have an
awesome sponsor on yang speaks
um called better help and it's
important any time of year but given
this lockdown pandemic we're all
enduring right now
it's even more um timely and relevant so
betterhelp will assess your mental
health needs
virtually and then match you with your
own licensed professional therapist so
it's online virtual
mental health and it's important now so
you can start communicating under 48
hours it's not a crisis line it's not
even self-help it's just professional
counseling done securely
online so you can send a message to your
counselor that you get anytime
you get these timely thoughtful
responses like real responses um and you
can schedule weekly video or phone
sessions and you don't have to sit in a
waiting room either which is nice um you
have to talk to your grandma about you
don't talk to anybody about it between
you and a professional and so you can
get
expertise in depression stress anxiety
relationships sleeping trauma
self-esteem grief you name it um and
right now for me it's energy it's like
how do i keep going how do i not lose my
mind i gotta take walks i gotta think
about how i'm processing emotions how to
care more it's a big thing i'm working
on having more empathy so i want you
guys to start living
happier life happy and healthy life
during this pandemic and as a listener
of yank speech you're going to get 10
off your first month which is great so
we visit our sponsor betterhelp.comyang
join over one million people have taken
charge of our mental health
it's a perfect time to do it that's
betterhelp.hep.com
yang
[Music]
one of the things that you said in your
book is that
business schools tend to be very very
extroverted
um and and i think there's something
around business culture that way
academia introverted i'm gonna say
law pretty introverted but business
the opposite absolutely though i will
say one
really nice development that i heard
about a friend of mine who
teaches at business school told me that
when she used to teach her leadership
course she would always start it by
having people do a personality test
and and it used to be that she
apparently had a class of 100
extroverts but she said that that's
changed over the years and now
half of the students identify as
introverts so i think what was happening
before
is that people felt like they had to
answer the test questions in a way that
would
make them seem extroverted but now they
don't feel that pressure to quite the
same extent
so i think we are seeing some changes in
the culture even though
i in general i agree with you um
business school culture is probably the
most extreme
i i actually you know you know from
reading the book i kind of plopped down
at harvard business school for a while
i was researching the book i just found
it the most fascinating
environment and i went there i i went to
do book research there because
a friend of mine had graduated and said
it was the spiritual capital of
extroversion
i always remember one guy who i
interviewed there who
who said there's this feeling of like
whatever you've done
it doesn't matter how inconsequential
the thing was you went to the
supermarket
you have to figure out a way to make it
um
an enticing story about that day that
you went to the supermarket
and he was a substance versus words guy
and he felt like he had to just like
keep on figuring out ways to raise his
hands in class even when he didn't
really have
anything like value-add
to say that sounds like a difficult
environment for someone like that
yeah yeah um so i would love to see
that kind of thing shift um
i mean i i'm always intrigued you're
probably familiar with
the the technique out of amazon
where apparently they begin
meetings really the week before the
meeting starts where the person who's
organizing it
has to write a whole lengthy
memo um detailing everything that
they're going to talk about
and this all happens way before the
meeting then everybody gets to the
meeting
and they sit down and the first thing
they do is for half an hour they sit
there
together reading silently this memo
before they talk about anything
and this is apparently an a a a
technique that was pioneered by jeff
bezos to
get everybody actually talking about
something meaningful as opposed to just
you know what usually happens where
people are just sort of
going on the fly and not really knowing
what they're saying
so so susan um you're a parent um
you have a two or three kids i have two
kids
yeah how do you think social media
plays into uh introversion
for kids in particular and i ask this
because i've got one boy who's very
um introverted and i have a sense that
social media is like the ultimate over
stimulation i don't know if you've seen
anything
um that actually shores up
my impression yeah i think it goes both
ways because social media is
on the one hand it's a way of kids being
able to communicate
without having to be out there in the
social scrum
in the same way you know putting aside
covered restrictions and stuff
but on the other hand social media is a
kind of bombardment of constant stimuli
all happening at once with a whole lot
of social judgment and social evaluation
layered in on top of the stimuli so in
that way it can
be a pretty demanding
social environment at that age there's
so much the feeling of like that you
know the main currency is
how many how popular are you how many
likes do you have how many followers do
you have
um how successful are you and and now
all of a sudden that's that's all
tangibly evaluated for everybody to see
that's a very difficult thing i think my
lucky star social media media didn't
exist when i was a kid
because is it when i was like a bookish
kid
hiding in my room um you know i was
alone
um it's not like if i took out my phone
all of a sudden my classmates were there
with me
right um i think it's very very
difficult for a kid to really escape
that
because when you're young what other
people
think about you seems like the entire
world exactly
and then if you can just access that on
a device
it strikes me as quite overpowering
when in in my life during that time i
would literally just be
reading some escapist science fiction
novel and that was like a much more
pleasant way to spend my time
than seeing what my classmates were
doing or worse yet what they thought
about me
exactly and i i also think that the um
the kind of social connection that it
encourages is so much more
performative um i'm thinking about
my adolescent ears and i you know i'd
come home and i had um
i had my best friends who i would talk
to every night on the phone and it would
be like one
long one-on-one phone call after another
where we would have these real
conversations with each other the way of
interacting was
based on a lot of trust and a lot of
intimacy and connection
it had nothing to do with performance in
the way that
everything in social media is and i
really worry about that
and what we're sacrificing
so andrew and i have gotten new
mattresses from helix sleep and we love
them
and now that andrew's in quarantine for
coronavirus he has sleep in his kid's
room and they do not have a helix
mattress for working on that
but they do not have one and he is
miserable poor guy
it's hurting his back and it's because
the key to a good night's sleep is
like 90 plus percent mattress and helix
sleep is awesome
you take a quiz go online and you get
matched with a certain
type of mattress i got matched with the
helix lux and it shows up in this like
very compact box you can get a bed frame
if you want to
and then you unwrap it and it like
literally pops open it's like wild it's
amazing like i don't know they suck all
the air out of it it's fantastic
and then it's one of the best night
sleep you've ever had so if you're
looking for a mattress take the quiz get
your mattress
all you do is go to helixsleep.com yang
take the two minute sleep quiz they'll
match you with a customized mattress
that'll give you the best sleep of your
life
seriously they have a 10 year warranty
you get to try it out for 100 nights so
like there's literally no risk to this
thing
and they've got a cool gift for you
you're going to get 200
off off all mattress orders so up to 200
off
all matched orders and two free pillows
which are also very comfy for our
listeners
that's helixsleep.com yang so helix
h-e-l-i-x
sleep.com yang for up to 200
off and two free pillows check it out we
love it
[Music]
i have a question for you just with that
incredibly vivid image that you just
painted of yourself and your
bedroom at that age reading your science
fiction so
what was the transition from that
to a life in
politics and i know it was by way of
five months of the law firm
but like if if if we went back and told
your 13 year old self
that you would be doing later what
you're doing now
would he be completely shocked or were
the seeds of it
there back then i think he would be
shocked
you know what what's funny is the seeds
of it i think were in those science
fiction novels
um i i said years later in a book
that's much less successful than yours
by my first book
um but it was that i said when i was a
kid
i dreamed about going in the woods and
slaying a dragon
um not being described uh
and could dig at my time as a lawyer
because i thought it was described yeah
so i was like this isn't what i was like
you know
put on this earth to do or my parents
immigrated to this country
for me to do um so
so i wanted to do something i was proud
of
maybe i really internalized the morality
of these
like fantasy or science fiction novels
but they tended to have like you know
someone
um overcoming some degree of like
challenger adversity for some
greater purpose uh and and so i thought
well i should try and do that too
and that started out with me
trying to start a business and failing
uh and then
working at a series of other startups
and then eventually
having some degree of success and then
the real
purpose-driven juncture was when i
started this non-profit
venture for america in 2011
and that required all sorts of new
behaviors
um and a lot of it susan is that
like i i see what my
organization needs and then i try and
adapt to fulfill
um that that role and so
this nascent nonprofit that i started
required me to become this
spokesperson ambassador type um and so i
started
taking that on but it was an evolution
over time because
starting from when i left the law like i
had
different degrees of customer facing
responsibilities
another thing that did happen to me when
i was young was that
i was on the u.s national public
speaking and debate team
in high school um and uh i ended up
competing
the world championships in london um
so so there was like a period when i was
made to think that i was an above
average communicator
and that time was still
based on my nerdiness in my mind
like you know it was that i was like you
know coming up with good
arguments and ideas but at some point
i started to feel like i could do these
things if i needed to
did you have um shyness about being
on stage when you were in high school
entering those competitions
or was it like if you were in the realm
of ideas then
then you were okay when i was younger
i was miserably uh
shy of being in the spotlight i remember
crying when i was asked to present in
front of the class
um so much so that eventually the
teacher just gave up
wow how old were you when that happened
uh maybe third or fourth grade something
along those lines
so what made you do public speaking and
debate team
in high school like was that a slaying
of a dragon in and of itself
or was it like you know this is ideas so
it's okay
one of the things that happened to me
susan is that like i i found myself
wanting to have different kinds of
experiences
like i didn't want to cut myself off
from various experiences
yeah but this is actually kind of true
my approach today
is that like i'm still just trying to
get stuff done like i kind of wanted to
have the experience and put myself
forward kind of independent
of like feeling like i was going to be
lauded for it or made fun of for it
seems like what you
did was set ego aside you were more
focused on the thing
in and of itself that's what it sounds
like
i still wouldn't say that i
sought it out or thrived on it um like i
think that i
i went for very very long periods of
time without that kind of
um experience and was totally fine
right right and if there were a way now
to
be in public service without having to
do all the
really out there front-facing things
that one has to do
um would you be perfectly happy my dream
susan
is that i could just like write things
put them out into the world and then
people would be like oh that's a great
idea we should do that
i totally understand i can't even tell
you how much
it's amazing that you um despite that
being your ideal that the path that
you've taken is really
interesting and well i i just really
want to get the thing done
yeah and and like i don't um and this is
the
the tough part about what we're talking
about susan is like
i i think that often people need a
person um
to step out there and make a case
um certainly that was the case for
universal basic income um
in the presidential and
like someone actually even asked me this
and i almost
choked um where they were like hey why
run for president why not just
you know write a book about it
and then i was like well one i did write
the book
and two like do you think anyone would
pay attention to like
you know a relatively anonymous
entrepreneur's book saying hey we should
you know what i mean like like that that
like not every book is like your book
where it actually
works
[Laughter]
i i mean i i'm so taken by that story
because
i think that you you're an extreme
example of what so many
introverts experience um like introverts
who are out there living
fulfilling and successful lives like
they may not do it to the
degree that you're talking about i i
think you're a pretty extreme example
um but i certainly don't recommend it
i don't know though i mean this is this
is one of the things
um as somebody who is a kind of
introvert advocate
this is one of the um the tricky
tightropes
that i think we all need to walk between
um
really honoring what our temperament is
and building a life that's as
constant with that temperament as we can
because why wouldn't you
um and then on the other hand um needing
as brightly
you talked about free trait theory which
is in my book and it's this
theory that is advanced by this amazing
guy named brian little
a personality psychologist um who talks
about how
we all in this life should be figuring
out what
what our core personal projects are and
those are the
the people and the causes and uh
the work that we're really dedicated to
and what he says is
in the for for the sake of those core
personal projects
those people who you love things that
matter for the sake of those things
you can and should be willing to step
out of character
um as long as you do it from a place
that honors who you are
and as long as you grant yourself what
he calls restorative niches where you
get to kind of
come back and be who you are and be in
your equilibrium
and take the day off and you know go
take a walk by the lake or whatever it
is
and um and and so i think a lot of
getting life
right is walking that balance between
just being who you are and doing the
stepping out of character
um but but also to know that there's
like there's such a huge difference
between stepping out of character for
the sake of
of being the proponent of universal
basic income
if that's what you believe um versus
doing it for something that you
don't really care about which i think is
the
dilemma that many people find themselves
stuck in
well i think that's one benefit of
introversion is that if you settle on a
belief
um you can settle on it very very
strongly you know
you have like real conviction i agree
with that
i agree um and i also think like the
converse is true that
that for introverts they're less likely
to
get swept up into something just purely
for the social benefits of it
so they're more likely to kind of do the
extra work of
crafting a life that really makes sense
for them substantively
on the public speaking front because i'm
sure there's a lot of people who are
listening who who wonder about that you
know because so many people have a fear
of public speaking
um and i can tell you like i i used to
be
completely terrified of public speaking
um and now i have this life at least
pre-covered
where i'm out giving talks all the time
to companies and schools and
like if you had told me years ago that
that would be my life i would have found
it ridiculous and impossible
but the evolution that i really went
through
was kind of what you were describing of
um
of learning when i'm speaking learning
to shift my focus
from the
from the ego of like how am i coming
across how are they judging me
you know leaving that behind and instead
focusing on
okay what is the idea that i really want
to communicate here and
and who is the person in the audience
whose life might be different
by virtue of having heard this um and i
always tell myself
if i ever get into that
feeling again of of you know of intense
jitters before giving a talk
i always tell myself well you know if
there's one person whose life or whose
child's life will be better as a result
of hearing this
then it's worth it and you're speaking
to that person
well you've made an enormous difference
in a lot of people's
lives susan you know my family is just
one example
if someone wants to find out more about
your work
the book is quiet the power of
introverts in a world that can't stop
talking at this point you have another
book
for families yeah so there's a website
at quietrev.com
um where you can find and that's for
quiet revolution so quiet rev.com
and on the website you can find
resources for
companies and for schools and and so on
and
that website is just out there
everything on it is
free whatever resources you might want
and um and then i also work personally
with companies and with schools
and in terms of connecting with me
online which is something i really
love love love to do with people um i'm
pretty active on social media
on linkedin in um
on facebook you can look for me under
author susan kane
and i'm also on twitter and instagram
susan kane the patron saint of
introverts
you've made the world friendlier for
many of us um and just made a lot of
people more mindful
about uh who they are uh it's
incredibly empowering a lot of folks owe
you a great debt
um and thank you for this conversation
this conversation was a restorative
niche for me
it has been a real pleasure to talk to
you and i didn't know
that whole background story i hope it's
going to be inspiring
for people to hear about i know it is to
[Music]
me
you